with more on this and reaction our top
story out of georgia in the recount
south carolina senator lindsey graham
center let me start with the secretary
of state at georgia
um there were others on the call and one
came to your defense and said
no that's not what lindsey said or did
at all
yeah well i really don't need anybody to
defend me because i know what i did and
i appreciate the person coming forward
i called the secretary of state to have
him explain to me how you verify his
signature on a melon ballot
not to throw out legal votes but to make
sure we have a system in georgia
that can verify that you are who you say
you are when you vote
if you show up in person you need an id
you don't need an id when you vote by
mail you go through the portal you need
an id but when you
apply for a mail and ballot through the
mail they have to verify your signature
a single person does that
in every county election office it
should be bipartisan
here's what i'm begging the trump
administration to do a campaign to do
challenge get some judge to go look at
the envelopes with signatures
and match them against the database with
somebody that knows what the hell
they're doing
in front of republicans and democrats so
we can verify
that melon voting in georgia is not
fraudulent when you have a single person
verifying a signature it's not
bipartisan i think that's not the way to
do it that's what i was talking about
stacy abrams is calling for every
liberal in the country to move to
georgia
she's bragging about having six hundred
thousand people ready to vote by mail
what i'm begging georgia to do is make
sure that if somebody votes by
by mail you have a bipartisan process to
verify the signature
we don't just leave it up to one person
in the election office
all right now you talk to the secretary
of state
the governor can call the legislature
back they haven't done that yet
what is the reason why why would you
have two separate systems on
on signatures and why is that okay i
mean you know look the more i get into
and how do you find 2600 votes yesterday
and another 2700 votes today
okay lindsay you know your state got it
right that for on
election night florida did ohio did all
these other states do
just pennsylvania michigan
nevada interesting the states that we're
worried about
well sean all i can say is on election
night votes came out of nowhere
for biden thousands showed up late in
the night on election night for biden
weeks later we're finding votes for
trump all i can say is i've said on your
show that voting by mail will be the end
of the republican party
if we don't have a system to verify
signatures
all i'm asking for is that georgia
have a bipartisan group to verify a
signature on a mail ballot
not leave it up to a single individual
here's what i predict
if you had an audit of all these
signatures on envelopes in georgia
and you had people who know what they
were doing i bet you the rejection rate
would be more than 0.3 percent
so if we don't get a better system when
it comes to voting about
voting by mail that's the end of the
republican party
and let it start in georgia folks stacy
abrams is trying to take over the
election system in georgia
fight back hey by the way how
you had more money thrown at you from
people
outside of south carolina roseau donald
barber straight we talked a lot about it
okay right people of south carolina
weren't influenced now all the money
from hollywood hollywood now telling
people to move there
which would be voter fraud side note um
right
and all this money is going to be
pouring into georgia
now i'm both those races matter purdue
and loffler
uh i am concerned that people you know
looking at this shift show
and a governor and a secretary of state
that have no urgency about it
they didn't get it right this time i i
think the secretary
of state owes everybody in the country
and answer
why we got 2 700 new ballots today 2600
yesterday
why they're why there's too standard why
don't they check the signatures why
wouldn't they do that
to ensure integrity and confidence in an
election
all i can say is that as georgia goes
the nation goes
democrats are calling for people to move
into georgia for the express purpose
of winning these two senate seats i had
money sent into south carolina
but nobody asked people from california
to move into south carolina
stacey abrams is calling for people to
move to georgia
to tip the balance of power in the u.s
senate
legislative arena in georgia i would
push back
because we're going to change the
supreme court from conservative to
liberal
we're going to do away with electoral
college so new york and california not
judges forever
30 days before the election they can
vote and then the vote's over they can
move out
that's what they're telling people to do
literally so please for god's sake
look at changing georgia law to
neutralize what stacy abrams
is trying to do she's going to send in
thousands hundreds of thousands of mail
in ballots
all i'm asking is have a bipartisan
group of people
verify the signature not a single person
and when it comes to moving to georgia
have a law that makes sure you just
can't move in for the purpose
of taking over the city and move out you
got a chance to change the law
change it you had twitter facebook
thoughts on today well
they got the most power in the history
of mankind they can all conspire to
tell us what we can see they can mold
how we think
they have no legal liability they can
take down your content
they can label what you say is
fraudulent you can't sue them
you have no no recourse as an individual
when it comes to them
censoring your content at the end of the
day section 230
is being abused it's now time to make
them like every other media organization
when you make editorial decisions you
become an editor
if fox news says something against me or
put somebody on television that slanders
me
i can not only sue the individual i can
sue fox news
in the world of social media there is no
accountability there is no legal
liability and there is no government
regulation
it is the wild wild west and we need to
fix it now because it will destroy
conservatism
if we don't get this right yeah it was
the media mob
big tech candidate protection program
and they never asked him any questions
and he got to hide in a bunker
this race january 5th a lot on the line
all right senator uh thanks for being
with us